How does one save a marriage when it
seems that there is no longer attraction
both physically and intellectually?
There are kids involved,
which is the main reason for
wanting to save the marriage.
Huh?
Well,
all right.
I know a couple of things about that.
I mean,
the first thing I would say is that if
you haven't had any intimate interaction
with one another for quite
a long period of time,
that can put both people into a stagnant
state where desire starts to slip away.
What,
what sex therapists recommend under
such conditions is to while essentially
start in some way,
start dating again.
So you could ask your partner to go
out to a movie or something like that.
And you know,
maybe when you come home you could,
you could neck for a little while.
Like teenagers,
that's probably a word
that no one uses anymore,
but kind of pull back
and you got to agree,
say not to,
um,
engage in full sexual
activity for a while,
but to tease each other and to play a bit.
Even if you're not attracted,
you have to act,
act it out for awhile and hopefully
you can get the motor running again.
The other thing I would say is that you
guys might want to sit down and make a
joint plan.
It's like what?
Cause I,
a marriage is like a story that two people
are acting out simultaneously and you
have to have shared goals and because
you're both rowing the same boat,
let's say,
and if you don't have
a destination in mind,
then,
well maybe you're rowing in circles
or maybe you're just standing still.
So I would say work hard to put some
romance back in the relationship.
You know,
you could say to each other,
look,
let's try this for six months
and just see how it goes.
We'll have two dates a
week for the first month.
We won't have any sex,
but we'll play around and then,
you know,
we'll see how that goes and,
and,
but we'll try it out for the,
for,
for the whole,
for the whole six months.
Um,
there are reasons to save a marriage.
I mean,
it's hard on kids.
Divorce is really hard on kids and
it's hard on the adults involved too.
Um,
so,
uh,
I would say
you have to negotiate
an agreement and you,
you know,
you could try the future
authoring program,
both of you.
What I would recommend for example,
is that you each do the future
authoring program separately.
So that's that self authoring.com cause
then you both have a life plan and then
you could sit down and read each other's
future authoring plans and see if you
have some things in common and then see
if you can figure out how to support
each other with regards to each
of you obtaining what you want.